let's talk some news man and uh this is
this is big this is trump trump vito's
major defense bill citing section 230
this is significant because
it's the authorization for national
defense it is a massive spending bill
it is a ridiculous spending bill the
most one of the most famous incidents uh
instances of the ndaa was when obama
signed into into law something called
the indefinite detention provision
which was included in it and allowed the
us government basically to like
rendition anyone anywhere like take you
and black bag you like you know like v
for vendetta where creedy puts the bag
over your head and then like
zips it and they drag you out that's
basically what it authorized so
you know seeing trump veto this i la
when i heard trump was gonna do when he
tweeted about it i started laughing but
let's read
techcrunch reports following through in
his previous threat
president trump has vetoed the 740
million okay million not billion
national defense authorization act a
major bill that allocates military funds
each year
in tweets earlier this month trump said
he would sink the ndaa
if it wasn't altered to include language
terminating section 230
of the communications decency act an
essential and previously obscure
internet law
that the president has had in his
crosshairs for the better part of a year
quote your failure to terminate the very
dangerous national security risk
of section 230 will make our
intelligence virtually impossible to
conduct
without everyone knowing what we are
doing at every step
trump said in a statement on the veto
it's not clear what the president meant
or what he was referring to in
criticizing the military
funding bill as a gift to china and
russia i just got to say i have no idea
what he means by that section 230 thing
and i think trump fundamentally
misunderstands what section 230 is
probably because his understanding of is
being filtered through
you know one or two people so you'll get
someone like me being like yo we need
section 230 reform section 230 is a
problem
someone will hear that and then be like
yeah section 230 is a problem and then
trump would be like it's a problem or
i'll get rid of it it's like no no
no you get rid of it we're all banned we
don't want to do that
so let's see they say uh trump tweeted
about it the president cited bipartisan
calls for a section 230 repeal in his
decision
in spite of the ndaa's overwhelming
bipartisan support so basically what's
going to happen now is mitch mcconnell
says december 29th
he's going to come back in override
trump's vetoes to make sure
every single trump supporter knows the
republican party hates you
hates your president i'm being a little
hyperbolic here but yeah come on mitch
mcconnell doesn't like trump
it was a really great comic i don't know
if you guys uh follow uh george alex
opolos who got his paintings up on the
walls
he just put one out where it's it
basically looks like the lion king i
guess
trump is hanging from a cliff and like
reaching out and then mitch mcconnell
jams his fingers into trump's hands and
then trump's like falling to his death
like the lion king and scar oh i want
that one yeah
so good man i'd love to get awesome but
uh look
if if section 230 goes our show's gone
the reason why there's probably
bipartisan calls to repeal section 230
is because the establishment hates us
they hate you they do now i'm not being
hyperbolic they hate you they hate me
they hate joey they hate ian
they especially hate lydia the
establishment really doesn't know what
is it about lydia i think i wanted
posters
because she's pushing the buttons man
that's true they're like
yeah so so look the establishment
democrats would love it if the
mainstream media were the only game in
town
and so you get rid of section 230 and
then overnight twitter facebook youtube
are flooded with lawsuits
many of them probably merit lists and
then they're going to be like we're done
ban everybody
we don't care you know you know what
youtube will do they would love this
youtube's been trying to get rid of
everybody for
a long time and so they're doing
something like uh i don't know if you
saw this joey with
what pornhub just did recently i did see
that banned all non-verified content
that's it if you're not a verified
channel you're going i used to have a
whole uh
photo pornhub channel yeah no like uh
bookmarked
like my favorite porn about it
yeah it's ten years worth of stuff i'm
with you
eighty percent of it's gone i'm like oh
this has
been my library you know evergreen
content you know the livelihoods for
some people
i mean in all seriousness a lot of
people just lost their jobs and that
happened
i know there's a lot i know there's like
pornhub like creators
like youtube yeah yeah yeah they'll do
like porn vlogs am i allowed to say that
yes i don't know i don't probably not
demonetize whatever
yeah whatever merry christmas everybody
but yeah but like it's it's like people
have their own channels and
you know they can make money i guess i
don't i don't i i uh my understanding is
now they're doing crypto because
mastercard and visa cut them off
but this is what's coming for everybody
they start with pornhub they always do
it this way too
because they know regular people won't
publicly fight for it
for the most part like nobody wants to
get on on a pedestal and be like we must
protect our porn
yeah they're going to be like yeah they
go after the worst of society first
or just like the socially the fringes
and now i'll tell you what comes next
they did this thing we talked about a
little bit last week where youtube got
rid of verification for
tons of channels you remember that yeah
that they i remember they stripped
i i wonder if i'm still verified well
they there was a backlash and so they
said okay we're not gonna do that we're
not gonna do that
i was actually one of the approved
channels where i got an email saying
you're all good we love you you're
verified but eventually i think what's
going to happen is they're going to
start
so right now they already said we're
going to put ads on
content that isn't in the partner
program meaning yeah you upload videos
you're not the part like they'll make
money off you because youtube's been
they're losing hundreds of millions of
dollars a year oh yeah non-stop
i think what comes next is they're going
to be like if you're not a verified
account in the partner program we are
going to stop promoting you in the
algorithm
and they're going to say you'll still be
or they'll say like we'll stop
recommending you as much
this is because you know we're trying to
improve quality for all of our creators
and make sure they can make money it'll
be great news for all of the bigger
creators who will now see bigger
viewership and things like that
and then they're gonna start they're
gonna tell they're gonna start getting
rid of smaller channels
fringe channels people with the wrong
opinions yeah
and you know what it's it's two things
they're doing it one
for business reasons and then two
because they have bias
and the business reasons why they're
doing it is because the whole
adpocalypse situations
where you know cnn or the late night
show they can post
whatever they want and they have reserve
ads on the back end
where they're what's that what does that
mean reserve it so well one
first off they're i'm assuming they're
in the google preferred program where
they're getting the most exclusive
highest paying ads
and then also on the back end to fill
the extra ad slots
they have direct deals with companies
like coca-cola
to fill that extra space and they pay a
premium so
obviously youtube and google they get a
cut of that so that's one of the reasons
why they want to promote you know
traditional media there because they
have their own
set of ads you know from from direct
deals uh so
business-wise it makes sense but that's
not what youtube is and those
that content only gets views when they
feature it on the home page right nobody
and it's when you go to the front page
of youtube i'm sure all of you watching
have seen this
there is like the covid news bar and
everything's thumbs down to oblivion
it's like
10 20 thumbs up it's all just
obliterated
because nobody wants to watch that
garbage yep so youtube's trying to be
netflix
if we get rid of section 230 youtube is
going to start square dancing all the
ceos will be laughing they're going to
be like that's it
all the conservatives all the moderates
independents you're gone
msnbc guys you know progressives all
right we'll give you a pass
but if if we keep section 230 the track
we're on right now
is still really bad for independent
voices
smaller channels or anybody who's even
big and wants to challenge the system
because you could have a million subs
but you give a wrong opinion you're gone
yeah and it's with with what these
social medias
the thing is i'm i'm more into the free
market where at first when this was an
issue like five years ago i was like ah
you know
they can do what they want their their
business you know they can operate
however they want but then over time
realizing
these social medias have been monopoly
on free speech on the internet
like the world wide web like if you make
your own website you can only
get generate traffic to your website is
if you promote it on twitter promote it
on youtube promote it on facebook
buy ads but buy a billboard i mean yeah
billboard on sunset
buy a billboard or a commercial on the
super bowl for a million dollars yeah
so how much that cost something like
that a million dollars a minute or
something are they more probably
way more than that yeah it's probably
like but like you can make a youtube
video it's
worth 10 times a commercial on the super
bowl i should i should buy a billboard
somewhere
well super bowl commercials are like
notoriously bad for no roi
like if you're a new company and you're
getting super bowl commercials like your
stock tanks
because all the investors yeah because
they know it's a bad investment i think
was pets.com is like one of the most
famous stories
i think it's bet one of those it was
like a pet type of website for adopting
animals
and they spent like tens of millions of
dollars and you know six
months later a year later they're out of
business wow because they got
no return on that investment and like
the problem with billboards and
commercials is that there's no click
through you can't like see a commercial
and click the button to go to the
website whereas on twitter you just
click the link
and you can target exactly who you want
to target everybody who loves pets and
animals anyone who's
googling how to buy a dog you can target
them
google set it up that way too they they
set up their algorithms to track what
people like so that you could use their
service to find people that like
what you're looking for yeah and they're
all sharing data so my girlfriend for
um for my birthday she got me an air
fryer
and she ordered it on amazon and then
we're watching tv we're watching imd
imbd tv we're watching malcolm in the
middle and an ad for that exact thing
that she bought
pops on the tv yeah the exact product
happens all the time
that's creepy yeah they know you better
than than you know yourself yeah
facebook knows when you poop i'm not
kidding i always read an article about
it
yeah because they like people don't
people don't realize that
there's things like your favorite color
correlates to
other things about you you know what i
mean so they could
someone could ask you a bunch of
questions that you think makes no sense
look like what's your favorite color
what's your favorite sport
you know where are you from and then
also they'll be like your favorite pasta
is you know
linguine pesto and you're like what
they're making like a statistical
analysis people who like this
also like that right you know if you
like all three of these things you're
definitely liking this fourth i'll tell
you what
the uh if youtube does the verification
purge
it's going to be really really good
business wise
for channels like this so right now
i i remember when youtube did that
announcement about what was it what was
it called like the cp
something the child protection act cpu
yeah and everyone's freaking out
all of the creators that do vlogs were
really worried
because they were like if we're deemed a
channel for children we don't get
access to targeted ads and our revenue
is going to drop like 80
and i started laughing i'm like wow this
is great i do politics there's
no way you're going to argue this
stuff's for kids and that means
they're going to we're going to get all
those those uh targeted ads and all that
everyone's gonna go more likely to us
than them
if youtube purges you know over time
from the partner program a bunch of
channels
that means and they start promoting more
verified and confirmed viewers
consolidate around
the top one percent you've got one
percent what do they say it's like 40
million
was it how many views per month youtube
got a billion
billion views but if you got a billion
channels and there's a billion views
you know you get one view per channel so
get rid of all but 10
channels and now everyone's getting
they're kind of doing it already their
select
group of favorite creators they're the
only ones that have access to the
trending tab
they're getting you know google premium
ads you know they're on
all the vidcon billboards you know i
think google youtube owns
the vidcon event which is like the
creator type of thing
trash event by the way that was made by
um the vlog brothers
didn't they didn't they inceptionalize
yeah that was uh the greens right yeah
yeah john
hank and john
[Music]
it's really it's really it's really
weird how the the social media drift
created this class of people who
were trying to out left each other
that's so weird it's like bro remember
where jon stewart used to be that's
where we were all
at but you guys kept trying to one-up
each other i guess to like prove your
value or virtue
yeah that's what they went further and
further left every single day that's
how they make themselves feel morally
superior
so they're morally superior to you
because they support black lives matter
they care about black people you don't
well but i think like you know like the
vlog brothers
were doing it because it was popular
marketing
so you know you get social media and all
of a sudden the craziest activists are
screaming at their lungs
and then you're like how do i get
attention wow everybody's talking about
this i should talk about this too
so you look it makes sense man if you're
trying to
if you're in the business of attention
where this is what we are this you know
like the goal of this show
what not directly is to keep people
watching it as long as possible
the goal of youtube facebook and twitter
is to keep you looking at that screen on
their website as long as possible it's
the attention economy
and then as we do we sell ads so for
for us it makes sense to talk about
important political news
and you know talk about what we believe
in and stuff and naturally that
generates an audience of like-minded
people
what they're doing is the inverse they
see a big audience of crazy far leftists
and they think
that's my path to make money now it's
funny as the leftists accuse
like us of doing that grifting of like
they're like tim poole used to be like
super left and now he's conservative or
whatever and it's like well first of all
like opinions change
like earlier this year i was not pro i
was not 2a
like hardcore as i am now now i'm like
very much 2a it's between you
kind of drifting a little bit more right
and then also the the spectrum of the
left
shift also shifting but i actually moved
uh further left
actually yeah so i you know my political
compass test i'm actually
further left libertarian i used to be
like pretty liberal now it's like down
and like more left libertarian
but uh leftists are not a lot of a lot
of conservatives don't get this
the actual economic left libertarian
they are pro-gun they're not anti-gun
it's it's the it's the establishment
elites the authoritarian
groups that are pro-gun even the
authoritarian communist types are
pro-gun
how they're going to have their
revolution yeah so they're definitely
pro-gun
they're very there's like as a reddit
page for socialist gun
rights and stuff like that so anyway but
what happens is
you have people like the vlogbrothers
who aren't you know look
i i'll leave them out of this but i'll
wrap them in the bigger picture
celebrity
what are celebrities for their marketing
that's it
they're people they are marketing the
reason why they put brad pitt in the
movies because they put brad pitt's name
on it you go see the movie
so the same thing with these youtubers
the goal is
they want to generate as much attention
as possible when they see
everyone's clamoring about social
justice they're like oh i can do that
too
i can do that too the right has that you
know there are certainly people who are
like
i've decided to support this or that
because it's going to make me money but
i think that's a tendency of the left
more so so it's like it's
disproportionate you have more leftists
or fake leftists to pretend to be left
doing that then you have people
supporting trump the people who support
trump tend to really support the guy
yeah and it's when trump you know
supposedly lost the election
i was just getting flooded with people
saying give it up already stop crying
you cry baby trump lost get over it i'm
like wait first off the election's not
over trump didn't concede whatever is
happening is happening
but i'm like they don't understand the
difference between having a passion
for the country a passion for actually
liking the president
they don't understand the difference
between having a passion and then
yelling and screaming and crying at the
sky
you know when trump lost election night
uh
we you know we took what's the legal
process let's investigate let's do this
let's do that
when the democrats lost in 2016 it was
just screaming and yelling at the sky
they did their they had their celebrity
videos where they were like the electors
you
must have overcome you must be faith
listen to fi
right now in iowa there's a woman her
name is rita hart she lost by
six votes guess what she's doing
suing to overturn the results arguing
that they should reinstate
22 mailing ballots that were
disqualified because then she wins
yeah and i say okay well you have the
legal right to do it by all means it's
funny though
when it's when these elections are that
close even trump you know
lost by you know ten thousand votes in
some states states with you know
three million four four million in
population ten thousand votes
nothing comparatively to the pocket well
you know trump only won 2016 by like 77
000 votes
yeah he he got a big electoral victory
but there were three states where he
only got like
point one percent like really you know
thin margins but it's funny to see
this dem the democrats are like when
we're you know when we lose it's okay
for us to overturn the results
and i don't see any of these news
outlets saying this is shaking
confidence in our elections and it's
evil and wrong now they're
in support of it the person who's who's
filing the student on her bf or like
who's working with a lawyer
is one of the lead critics of trump in
his legal effort
to overturn the results so it's like
this guy goes on twitter all day and
he's like
trump is you know what he's doing is
wrong and he's going to lose it's
ridiculous how dare he and then i'm
going to file the exact same lawsuit for
my person
don't look over here everybody the left
their their ideology is like a sliding
scale there's no consistency it's like
all about what benefits them at that
particular moment at that point in time
right
where one day the left can be on twitter
praising the constitution because
something went their way
and then the next day say with the
constitution was founded by a bunch of
racists right right and now we need to
destroy it so yesterday you just loved
the constitution because it helped you
now you want to worse of course i was
thinking that power
of just kind of in general the power
they say power corrupts people
and that we this social media uh
view count is like a source of power
when you have the ability to go
click a button and tell someone
something and a thousand people here you
say it
that people are getting slowly driven
insane and then when they get the likes
and they're like oh when i did that
complaint it got a bunch more likes from
those crazy and then they get even
crazier
and so you've got people in politics
going crazy we call them
the left or the people in social media
like brad not brad pitts crazy but these
cult
you know these these youtubers that
ended up like the vlog
yeah and it happens on both sides too i
mean it happened
with me at points on twitter it's like
okay let me keep saying this and it
keeps me
more and more likes or let me make
videos on this and just
push the edge it drove me to insanity in
the early days of youtube i thought the
only reason people looked at me was
because i was crazy like i would smoke
weed and talk about the craziest stuff
people like this guy's insane this guy's
insane but those videos would get the
most
views exactly and so i kept doing it and
tried to out insane myself and i was
getting depressed and
it drove me insane i almost killed
myself it was that's why i went
i i'm so controversial online with my
pranks because
the algorithms were rewarding being
controversial being offensive
you know doing crazy crazy just crazy
and crazy and you get to that point
where you're realizing
oh wow i took it kind of far
and then you kind of take that step back
there's people who
who uh don't realize they get they get
caught in the algorithmic loop
and then they start producing more and
more and more i think people need to
need to recognize what this is but i
will tell you something
these big tech companies will ban the
right so the wall is set
right so if you're if you're on the
right and you start
seeing you'll tweet something you'll get
more likes so you tweet more of it you
go crazy
you get more followers you get more
shares then twitter bans you
you went too far they say we see you go
too far
you should have stopped it's too bad
you're out on the left
you can literally call for riots and
terrorism and violence
and they won't remove it yeah listen to
this i when i got banned on twitter i
made another account called not joey
salads whatever
and it was not me somebody else was
running it and for me
and i did i actually i went through
three different twitter accounts
so that account in particular got banned
because i said i replied to the la mayor
saying
but sure just let them burn the city
down sarcastically
because he was talking about black lives
matter what not yeah and i got banned
for inciting violence
immediately the very next day
was when they were calling for riots
because uh
rbj or ginsburg died yeah the very next
day was trending
burn it down or whatever of course of
course man and i i got banned for being
sarcastic
when i was on the joe rogan show with
the people from twitter
we pulled up a tweet that had been up
for months
that was calling like those of us i
think the tweet itself was a felony
and i was like why is that tweet still
there and they're like uh
i don't know oh we can't monitor every
single tweet
and i was like but you could see that
replies to it were banned yeah so you
had this tweet from an antifa account
calling for overt violence instructing
people to commit violent you know
felonious acts and it was fine
below it it was like this tweet has been
removed for violation of policy this is
remove remove remove removed yeah
and so when they were like well you know
people have to report these things for
us to notice and i was like
the replies are banned clearly people
are reporting this like crazy
and each other yeah i'm telling you
right now they all these social medias
if they don't they're stupid they
definitely have
certain key phrase algorithms that
determine if you tweet
saying i want you to burn whatever down
whatever they know in their algorithm
and i know tick tock does this a lot if
they scan the video and they notice
something that's questionable
they'll actually put the video on hold
send it to a review
to determine okay was this a violation
okay it wasn't and then it gets cleared
so you i mean you know what you know
what tic toc used to do they were
it was really clever if if on uh uh
youtube somebody is getting cyberbullied
youtube will ban the bullies
on tiktok if somebody was getting
cyberbullied they'd ban the victim
because think about it makes a lot of
sense if you don't want bullying on your
platform
do you ban the 300 bullies or the one
victim
well yeah if you want your user numbers
to be inflated
you don't want to ban 300 people can't
do that ban the victim yeah now the
bullying is gone congratulations only
beautiful people to be on our platform
yeah tick tock has done a lot of sketchy
stuff when it comes to you know
favoring beautiful people algorithm
it's weird because when i'm on tick tock
i even though it's owned by china or in
bed with china
it's it's still i think more free
speech than you know the other platforms
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time